okay let's get to an update on the Jim
Acosta story Jim Acosta is a CNN
reporter he asked questions of Donald
Trump which I know to many of you will
not come as a shock since that's what
many reporters do and Donald Trump
didn't like the questions and during
this question-and-answer period there
was an incident where a White House
intern started to try to physically
remove the microphone from Jim Acosta
while Trump and Acosta were arguing
Acosta's arm got tangled up with the
interns here's the original clip that
started all of this a long way that
that's not an evasion honestly I think
you should let me run the country you
run CNN or and if you did it well your
ratings let me ask you mr. president
are you worried that's enough
other folks that said now pardon me
ma'am mr. president that's enough this
president I had one of these I may ask
you on on the Russian investigation are
you concerned that that you may have not
concerned about anything with you
investigation because it's a hoax are
you that's enough put down the mic mr.
president are you worried about
indictments coming down in this
investigation mr. president I'll tell
you what CNN should be ashamed of itself
having you working for them
you are a rude terrible person yeah so
then after this the story from the White
House became we are getting rid of Jim
Acosta from these briefings because he
put his hands on a woman and then video
was released which was apparently edited
in a way to make it seem as though the
moment where the arms get tangled
between Acosta and the intern was a
moment of Jim Acosta being violent in
some way with this intern and we
reported on the video when it first came
out it appeared quite a bit as though
there was something up with it and it
seems that it was sort of a combination
of speeding up the moment where Jim
Acosta zarm goes in downward direction
with potentially even removing some
frames to make that downward motion
looks sort of more aggressive and we now
have an interview that Trump adviser
Kellyanne
'we gave on fox news sunday where she
admits that this video was indeed edited
but she called it not edited not altered
not doctored simply sped up and her
language here is completely Orwellian
and i'm gonna play it for you and then
we'll talk about it take a look this
brings me to my final subject which is
the now infamous confrontation with Jim
Acosta at that news conference as you
know I have been very critical of
Acosta's behavior myself but I want to
ask you about two responses by the White
House first to tweet a video that was
clearly altered to make it look like it
was more of a physical confrontation
than it really was although I do think
it wasn't appropriate and second to pull
Acosta's pass to get into the White
House and to threaten to do that to
other reporters well Chris first of all
what do you mean by edited or as others
are saying quote doctored video he
either put his hands on her and grabbed
the mic back or he did not he clearly
did no good but the video was altered
and their experts who have looked up to
make it look party oh well that's not
altered that's sped up they do it all
the time and sports to see if there's
actually a first down or a touchdown so
I don't I have to disagree with the I
think overall description listen I watch
a lot of sports on TV has she ever seen
sports on TV in sports you do slow
motion to see what happened you don't do
fast motion like have you ever seen
referees Pat say you know we really
didn't get a clear look at that can you
show us a replay in 2x speed so that we
can really figure out what's going on
like that this is one of the dumbest
explanations so far the only thing I can
think of is like on a highlight reel if
you're showing a football player making
a 90 yard run maybe you'll speed that up
because the clip takes a little bit of
time but if you're trying to focus in on
something like I don't know a fumble or
whether a runner was safer out at the
plate you want to slow that down so the
public can actually get a look at what
happened yeah the idea that you would
speed something up
to ascertain what actually took place is
ridiculous and of course this is part of
the words have no meaning thing anymore
Kellyanne Conway of the Bowling Green
massacre which didn't exist of
alternative facts which of course it's
sort of binary something either is a
fact or it is not a fact it was sped up
at a particular moment to create a
different perception of what it is that
took place period the idea that changing
the speed of a video is irrelevant
because it's just the playback speed is
ridiculous imagine your honor there's no
way I was speeding check out this video
of me driving at the time right before I
was pulled over look at how slowly I'm
moving well that video has clearly been
altered no your honor it's not been
altered I've simply slowed the video
down well yet what's at issue is how
fast you were driving so slowing the
video down is an alteration that's
what's at issue here they can't be
trusted
to tell the truth about anything like
stupid things irrelevant things
important things they they can't be
relied upon to give us the truth about
anything and in the end why not just say
you know what the video was altered we
regret sharing an altered video put
together by a conspiracy website but we
believe that Jim Acosta's behavior is
what was inappropriate it's not the
speed at which he chopped a female
interns arm we simply don't want him
around because we think that his
presence is toxic like Pat why not just
save that you don't need doctored video
to defend your decision some people are
gonna be happy with your decision to
kick them out others are going to say
let's file a lawsuit which is exactly
what CNN has done and we'll talk about
tomorrow but it's not that the video is
even necessary for them to do what they
want
you can totally concede that the video
was altered and still try to feign the
moral high ground in that exchange
because they could still say that Jim
Acosta acted inappropriately and that's
not the demeanor that you expect from
the White House press corps you can go
in that direction but Kellyanne Conway
she has to stick to it
doubling down time and again with just
absolute and total fabrications today's
program is sponsored in part by Fair
indigo dot-com who is giving everybody
in our audience 15% off their first
order only when you use the promo code
Pakman at checkout I talk all the time
about how harmful the garment industry
can be both in terms of the environment
and workers rights which is why I'm very
excited to tell you about Fair
indigo dot-com which is a clothing
company focused not only on the extreme
quality and longevity of their products
but also actually making sure that the
people making the clothes actually get a
fair and living wage and that every step
of the manufacturing process is
eco-friendly if you're watching on
YouTube right now I'm wearing the
organic pima cotton hoodie which is
extraordinarily comfortable fair
Indigo's clothing is made from premium
alpaca and ultra high-quality organic
pima cotton the softest and longest
lasting cotton on earth it's grown by
small-scale farmers without any
pesticides and all of the garments are
manufactured at a mill that recycles
100% of its water uses earth-friendly
dyes and everything is cut and sewn by
experts at their Lima Peru workshop
where all workers are actually paid fair
wages go check out everything they have
for both men and women everything from
short and long sleeve t-shirts polo
sweaters hoodies to women's tops dresses
and scarves there's really something for
everybody and these are styles that
don't get old so it's clothing you'll
want to wear for years with quality that
ensures you'll actually be able to click
the link under this video shipping is
always free on orders over $75 and
you'll save 15% when you use the promo
code PA que ma n at checkout